today for our daily cancellation a video
that may or may not be totally staged
and fake honestly i didn't do much
research into it before i started
shooting the show today
mostly because i'm lazy and also because
i really need this video for show
content so
i'm gonna assume it's real you see i
like literally everyone else in media
i am at this point barely human i think
of everything in terms of whether i can
use it for content that's the only thing
i care about
actually i can relate to the jogger
filming his own potential mauling
because i might do the same
to be honest with you like if i were to
accidentally drive off of a 500-foot
cliff
the last thing i would think as i
plunged to my death is that at least if
i somehow survive this
it will make great content but anyway
my sociopathy isn't really the point
today the point is that this video
which appears to show a woman fed up
with her boyfriend
you know and fed up with him not sealing
the deal deciding to put on a wedding
dress and a fanny pack for some reason
grab her enabling bridesmaid and somehow
a minister
and go to her boyfriend's job which is
at target to force him to marry her
this is really a form of kidnapping it
seems to me but uh
here is the the footage watch this
and it's time to do it or get out now
we're getting married right now
or i'm leaving i'm out i'm done
like if you're going to marry me this
second i brought the pastoral
hi guys i'm just finally making him
commit
you know like we're getting married now
or like it's over
do it yeah we can't talk about
now perhaps unsurprisingly i am
canceling all parties concerned here i
cancel the would-be bride on the general
grounds of her
apparently being a lunatic though i
suppose she gets points for getting
married in a target parking lot rather
than doing the whole elaborate
traditional wedding routine because if
she did the traditional wedding routine
one shutters to imagine what sort of
bridezilla she would be
she strikes me as the type of bride who
would break down in tears in the middle
of reception because
the napkins are the wrong shade of white
or something
in fact now that i think of it we may be
asking the wrong question about this
incident we're asking whether it's
staged but do we even know
if that guy was actually her boyfriend
how do we know they knew each other at
all maybe she met him for the first time
the previous tuesday
when she went to target and he was
working and she stopped
him to ask ask if they sell sweaters for
poodles and
his friendliness gave her the impression
that they were madly in love
so she showed up a few days later with a
priest and demanded that they marry on
the spot
you know it's a tale as old as time
classic love story could be the case
here
we really don't know but she's she's
she's canceling cancelled i also
cancelled a man though because
a couple of reasons first of all you
have done something wrong
in your relationship if you have given
your girlfriend the impression
that it would be acceptable for her to
come to your work in a wedding dress
and ask to get married real quick on
your lunch break
also i'm cancelling him on the
assumption let's just assume
that it's true that he's been engaged to
her for two years
and is stringing her along her approach
here is ill-advised on a number of
levels but
she's right at least that two years is
too long so she's correct on that score
i'll defend her there
so he is canceled for that and they are
canceled together they have that in
common at least
perhaps it can serve as the foundation
for their new life together as a married
couple
their mutual cancellation i don't know
now i understand
that people today people in my
generation
uh are afraid of marriage allergic to it
that's why marriage rates have been
dropping while unmarried cohabitation
skyrockets and i understand to some
extent
uh why this fear of marriage is there
it's it's
somewhat justified older generations the
boomer generation
they complain about millennials being
afraid of commitment but
where do you think we contracted this
particular disease from
baby boomers got divorced like it was
their hobby like it was their favorite
thing in the world to do my parents are
still married but
growing up half of my friends had
divorced parents by the time i was in
middle school so
a lot of people in my generation grew up
in broken homes
and didn't get the greatest example of
marriage if you're wondering why your
kids
don't want to get married consider the
possibility that they were turned off
from the whole enterprise
because you suck so bad at it maybe
that said um you could only use mommy
and daddy as an excuse for so long and
swearing off marriage doesn't really
make sense
unless you're going to swear off
romantic relationships completely and
live a celibate life in which case
more power to you there's something to
be said for that perhaps but
if you still want to have that sort of
companionship
then you really have two ways of going
about it number one
strive to find and form a lasting
committed stable relationship with
someone you
who you can come to know and love and
with whom you can build a family
and a life together and grow old by each
other's side
or two you can wander from one
meaningless self-centered temporary
relationship to another
the thrill of something new quickly
giving way to dissolution and heartbreak
again and again and again
until finally you're too old for that
sort of thing
your physical beauty wears away and
ultimately you're left alone with no one
by your side an old age and
no child to care for you those are
really your two options
that's really it of course option one
can turn into option two if the marriage
doesn't work out but still
at the end of the day these are broadly
speaking what you have to choose from
if you don't wanna be celibate and
become a hermit which again
more power to you if that's what you
want to do to each their own but i would
highly recommend option one and if
you're gonna go with option one
that requires some decisiveness and yes
a little bit of risk you're never gonna
know
everything there is to know about
someone before you get married there's
always gonna be some mystery
in the other which is a good thing if
you look at it the right way
and that means there's always going to
be a little bit of a leap you have to
take when you tie the knot
yet yet putting off the leap won't
accomplish much
there's only so much you can feasibly
learn about somebody
before you've married them it's part of
the bargain
and as far as that goes you'll have
learned almost all that you can learn
very quickly one thing i hear from
people a lot is that well
you know we have to live together for
five years before marriage
to find out if the other person has
annoying habits are you kidding
of course they have annoying habits
everyone does i have approximately 900
000 annoying habits my wife has counted
all of them
but you learn to have fun with the
annoying habits at least i do
my wife doesn't like the sound of
chewing so what do i do well
when we're watching a movie um i i
intentionally
chomp on a bowl of tortilla chips just
to piss her off
it's a great time intentionally annoying
her is my love language
because i'm essentially still in sixth
grade emotionally speaking
so don't worry about that sort of thing
you you it'll happen your work around it
um i tend to think you can know if
somebody is marriage material
and whether you want to marry them in
like a month
i know i did with my wife but let's be
cautious and say
six months by six months you will know
almost everything you can know about
that person before marriage
it's possible they're hiding some deep
dark secret it's possible your beloved
is a chainsaw murderer
but frankly if you haven't figured that
out in six months of dating you probably
won't figure it out in six years either
and besides chainsaw murdering isn't a
deal breaker in a marriage
you can work around that too spice of
life and all that
so make your decision in six months get
engaged
get married six months after that one
year is all you should need
one year that's it one and done let's
say that's what i did
and so i decided that of course everyone
else should do it too
and when i am theocratic fascist
dictator of america this will be
obviously required by law under my
regime upon reaching upon reaching
adulthood you will be given six months
to find someone and get married if you
don't find anyone
somebody will be assigned to you the
wedding will be carried out shortly
after that
there will be no reception as music and
dancing will be of course banned
and then you'll have 24 hours for
honeymoon at six flags or something
before being sent to
work in the factories for the rest of
your life there may be a few flaws in
that sort of system i admit but
it's better than what we're doing now in
fact really anything is better than what
we're doing now
uh actually what you just saw there is
is is is
probably better than the way that most
people my generation handle
relationships so
maybe i don't cancel them in fact maybe
i cancel everybody else
you know and look they have a great
story to tell their kids one day
if everything works out um
and i you know i i think that uh should
it go that way
when the kids finally hear that story
they won't be surprised because they'll
know their mom and
and they'll hear that story and think
yeah well it sounds like mom
all right so who am i canceling uh i'm
i'm canceling uh commitment averse
millennials i guess that's that that in
the industry was canceled
i guess the guy the guy is canceled not
the woman
we we went on a circuitous path here but
this is where we ended up
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right
down there so you can stay up to date on
all of our future content